katia bonjour je viens de le dire vous
êtes donc sur place et versailles quelle
est la situation en ce moment bonjour et
bien la situation c'est que je me trouve
à la fin d'un cortège d'environ 100 à
150 peut-être même 200 syndicalistes ou
autres grévistes venus protester contre
la tenue de cet événement à versailles
l'événement choose freine donc vous
devez voir derrière moi ces
syndicalistes en train de marcher
escorté par la gendarmerie
donc c'est la troisième vers troisième
édition de ce sommet regroupant des
entrepreneurs le but évidemment c'est de
faire venir des investisseurs étrangers
il y aura une série de réunions
bilatérales soient avec emmanuel macron
lui-même soit avec une vingtaine de
ministres qui seront présents à cet
événement le but c'est de présenter des
annonces pour stimuler la venue
d'investisseurs étrangers vont être
annoncées par exemple des mesures de
reprise de site industriel clé en main
avec des démarches administratives
facilitées car elles peuvent rebuter
évidemment les patrons étrangers car
c'est très compliqué de monter une
entreprise en france et puis l'autre
l'autre chose aussi ce sera une série
d'annoncés concernant l'ère post ben
l'exit avec des déménagements de sièges
sociaux
mais évidemment tout cette ce grand
raout à versailles n'est pas du goût des
grévistes qui sont venus de différents
syndicats aujourd'hui fo sud solidaires
à la cgt et jean est
aussi donc diverses diverses
sensibilités hiver grévistes qui
contestent la tenue de cet événement
destiné au patronat comme il dit je vous
propose d'écouter une réaction ce matin
devant la gare de versailles chantiers
au profit de l'occasion de la venue de
monsieur macro à versailles qui vient
par se réunir avec 200 patrons étrangers
pour faire la promotion de la france et
des investissements en france pour lui
rappeler que nous sommes toujours
opposés à la réforme des retraites
par ailleurs c'est aussi l'occasion de
mettre l'accent sur le fait que la
présidence est davantage tournée vers le
patronat que vers les salariés
donc on souhaite s'exprimer afin qu'on
soit vraiment entendu parce que pour le
moment on a le sentiment que notre
président vie en dehors du temps et
l'espace et qu'il n'a absolument pas
pris la mesure de l'ampleur de la
mobilisation en france qui dure depuis
plus de quarante cinq jours maintenant
il y à issy des personnels de la ratp de
la sncf de très nombreux enseignants qui
construit conteste bien entendu cette
réforme des retraites
ils veulent son retrait mais il ya
également d'autres revendications
portées par des personnes et délégués
syndicaux venus notamment des yvelines a
ils demandent la revalorisation des
salaires aussi bien dans le privé que
dans le public des mesures pour lutter
contre la précarité des plus jeunes et
puis l'exonération des exonérations la
fin des exonérations patronales
en tout cas nous suivons la situation
ici nous irons jusqu'au château de
versailles en compagnie des manifestants
qui sont escortés par les gendarmes
katia merci pour toutes ces précisions
je rappelle que vous êtes en direct de
versailles